l'actualité en france est d'avoir la
première grande enquête la première
grande synthèse sur les effets des
téléphones portables et des antennes
relais nocifs ou inoffensif on a tout
entendu tout et son contraire
et bien cet expert mandaté par l' agence
pour la sécurité sanitaire ont tranché à
ce stade aucune nuisance n'a été
constaté mais les précautions s'imposent
par éclairs samitier nicolas chateauneuf
les antennes relais serait sans danger
pour la santé
c'est ce qu'affirme le nouveau rapport
de la ce l' agence de sécurité sanitaire
environnementale rapport rendu public ce
matin des travaux internationaux publiés
montrent qu'il n'y a aucun danger avec
les antennes relais
contrairement à ce qui est avéré par des
associations entre eux ce qu'elles
prétendent à propos de saint cyr l'école
par exemple les associations ont obtenu
que les opérateurs démonter les antennes
relais situées sur l'école mais elle
déplore les huit cas de cancers
d'enfants à saint cyr pour les
associations ce nouveau rapport est plus
que troublant on a démontré une
perméabilité à sion de la barrière entre
le sang et le cerveau
c'était des travaux d'ailleurs qui a été
fait dans le cadre du rapport initial du
rapport ce miro qui maintenant sont
marginalisés qui ne sont plus cités dans
le rapport aujourd'hui
en revanche le rapport recommande
l'utilisation de l'oreillette pour les
téléphones portables
nous allons demander au gouvernement que
ce soit dorénavant obligatoire la
délivrance du kit oreillette dans tous
les paquets qu'ils soient vendus par les
opérateurs ou par des constructeurs ou
bien au supermarché ça c'est une forte
recommandation
un chercheur de borno a en effet montré
que des rats exposés à des portables ont
alors un cerveau qui subit de fortes
modifications il a vu qu'il y avait des
effets sur les vaisseaux du cerveau du
seuil de lattes qui se dilate un peu
comme on voit dans la migraine
les associations contestent les
scientifiques qui ont rendu ce rapport
et réclame la nomination de nouveaux
experts mais pour mémoire il y
actuellement en france 38 millions de
téléphones portables en circulation pour
60 millions d'habitants rappelons le est
on recense 33000 antennes relais
toujours l'électronique